[Musique]
alors soyez là où la bienvenue à votre
thème canada du quinze jours ce mot
aujourd'hui au jour n'est pas tenue du
16 avril
joyeuses pâques vous en fait ils sont
pas convaincus ce parce qu'on est
véritablement vendredi sur facebook live
ni on regarde le meilleur le dessin pour
la fin donc 16 avril on est en
rediffusion sur youtube et sur le site
de rci net.com jour d'hui jour de pâques
on va se mettre quelque chose sous la
dent
oui peut-être question des peurs et des
plaisirs des petits plaisirs et des
grandes peurs au sujet de la
légalisation de la marijuana au canada
il y en a c'est qu'on allait parler du
show on peut en mettre dans le chocolat
de la marijuana
c'est vrai sauf au canada la loi va
interdire la production de bonbons de
produits alimentaires qui pourrait être
qu'on mangeait par erreur par les
enfants ou par les états c'est une
meilleure des préventions assez
importante voilà et beaucoup de choses
qui ont été discutés dans ce projet de
loi qui a été déposé au canada on pense
que c'est l'an prochain enfin au 1er
juillet fait cent cinquante et unième
anniversaire du pays qu'on pouvoir
consommer légalement
pour le moment c'est interdit mais si on
regarde les preuves qui est prévu dans
la loi
oui combien de grammes vous pourrez
comme canadiens et aux canadiennes
posséder à avoir en votre possession de
façon légale pas l'année vous pourriez
acheter non pas pour aujourd'hui mais
manquait au quotidien je ne sais pas
mais je sais qu'ils en uruguay par
exemple c'est 40 g
à sa gauche ça fait 10 kg mais tant que
vous n'avez pas plus que de 2,2 g 100 g
20 grammes et est ce que c'est par jour
par année par mois au moment même à la
saisie on va mettre dix disent ouais par
jour non c'est trois grammes attentes et
les 30 grammes nom m'a coûté combien
baisse parce que là j'ai pas le droit de
montrer sa la caméra s'est pas encore
l'égal flore atteint d'une année si vous
aimez mais là je veux pas encourager
personne mais je veux voir ces cons
c'est l'équivalent de 30 grammes alors
ça c'est pas là mais oui vous voulez
sentir souvient de ce gip culture
oui c'est mon copain de la grc de mon
sens la terre mais c'est de la tête
en tout cas vous cultiver pour cultiver
des graines là dedans mais c'est pas
comme attendu mais c'est plus lourd que
trop gras oui c'est l'inter c'est plus
lourd en terme de volume sony vous avez
jeté un sac à dos oui on achète
oui chaque de vidage complet
[Rires]
sérieusement veux pas faire la promotion
de la drogue et cette émission au
contraire on veut débattre du pour et du
contre et déjà on a une question tam tam
à notre émission je ne sais pas ce que
vous avez eu 20 de cette question anne
marie vous qui étiez au service de
espace autochtone cette semaine vous
avez eu vent de cette question tant de
temps canada auquel les gens peut
répondre non non mais vous n'êtes pas
sans nous a pas donné de feuille de
route
ah ben oui bien sûr ah mais oui bien sûr
j'ai déjà la semaine dernière vous aviez
prévu qu'il serait question aujourd'hui
deux de nos inquiétudes nous donnons aux
réjouissances vis-à-vis la légalisation
de la vente de la marijuana et vous
l'avez dit ça va se passer en fait ça va
être ça va arriver l'année prochaine
j'ai compris je voulais la lire
également fou de rage et ruiné quelque
chose je alors la question comme tams et
voyez-vous venir avec inquiétude ou
réjouissances la légalisation de la
vente de la marijuana prévues pour la
fête du canada le 1er juillet 2018 alors
l'inquiétude ou les suisses ans alors
d'abord réaction de gérard winter au
niger qu'est ce qu'il dit on va demander
à aller on aura du prologue gedar je dis
ça ne changera rien dans ma vie sinon
enlever les risques d'un dossier
criminel pour une substances moins
dangereuses que l'alcool et maryvonne
les actions qui vient du québec a signé
daniel paquin c'est très long ah oui
alors il dit m
ce reflux on va s'abattre sur nos jeunes
et dans notre atmosphère imaginons des
publicités de potes par tou tv sur les
panneaux bord de route
tout ça pour protéger la santé de nos
enfants diminue et le marché noir
diminuer la population carcérale
ramasser des taxes et des votes pour le
petit peuple des dangers sur la route et
au travail partout odeur de potes
oh la la
d'accord au centre d'ici d'ailleurs on a
juste à quitter radio-canada marché
quelques pas et déjà ça sent
actuellement prochain alors je
traversais la rue l'autre jour et ça
sentait ça sort tout véhicule et tout de
suite après il y avait un véhicule de
police yeux pas trop profond mais ya pas
eu d'arrestation mais vous savez gay au
colorado
c'est un état aux états unis où la vente
de marijuana est légal est par contre la
consommation de la drogue s'est fait
juste chez soi alors ça pose un problème
pour les touristes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de place au
rallye finit donc pas de calais fineman
sternum par exemple n'ont peut-être
qu'ils peuvent se mettre dans un ballon
gonflé la yaris et ils sont entrés ou
d'essayer de voir s'il dans les bars et
dans des endroits comme les gens peuvent
fumer la marijuana mais pour l'instant
c'est interdit sauf qu'on peut pas fumer
la cigarette dans les bars dont est ce
qu'on va nous laisser fumer la marijuana
j'essaie pas ici mais là bas sont en
train de discuter des conditions de
l'application c'est pas réglé assez des
choses que sud d'abéché ccss en fait si
vous permettez ya juste un pays au monde
qui maintenant à légaliser le contrôle
de la vente la consommation et la
production de marijuana et c'est
l'uruguay alors ya quand même une
expérience assez intéressante qui s'est
fait un peu à nous le we can oui et puis
dans les colorado et je pense qu'il faut
quand même analyser ces expériences là
pour donner des réponses plus
scientifique aux questions qu'ils se
posent sur la consommation de la
marijuana lors je retiens une chose il
faut encore blâmer les latinos pour les
projets que l'on ait aucune
[Rires]
ils ont tenté et c'est lui qui a créé
qui a poussé cette loi lacey tpt moxico
l'ancien président de l'uruguay
et puis lui quand on lui a posé la
question et j'ai pas c'était jean-michel
les princes de radio-canada qui lui
avait posé la question dans une entrevue
il dit pourquoi vous parce que lui il
fume pas ils ne s'intéressent pas la
marijuana mais il a dit écoute et un
détenu à nourrir 1 sur 3 et dans les
prisons c'est tout vent l'a pris dans
les prisons à cause des la drogue
alors ça m'a d'essence il faut faire
quelque chose alors j'ai un petit jeu
questionnaire a pas dit il faut que je
finisse c'était très long parce que
c'est intéressant ça veut dire après
alors exit partout odeur de potes là il
rajoute plus de conflits familiaux
décrochage scolaire la désintoxication
notre mentalité latine exploiter rendra
le peuple anesthésié aulas la création
de dépendance qui est ouverte vers
d'autres drogues encore pour le fric et
il termine en disant d'un autre côté il
n'aura plus d'opportunités pour ceux qui
résisteront je voulais apocalyptique
apocalyptique que son commentaire
il ya des pays où la drac jeu s'est
passé
en europe il ya un pays où on peut
consommer dans la vie y'a pas ces gens
des choses qu'on voit dans ces messages
il faudrait que kiki la loi et il soit
sur sa main ouverte mais qui reste très
bien la limite c'est pour ça qu'il n'y
aura pas le choix c'est leur saveur yann
gross soleil qui vient de sonner vous
avez entendu mais c'est pas parce que
l'ordinaire et imaginaire aux finisseurs
du de la vidéo virale la semaine nuit
dans ce cas ci ne s'agit pas d'une vidéo
filmée cette semaine les films il ya mon
dieu il y as combien d'années aux 7 en
est-ce que vous souvenez de cette vidéo
virale portant sur la consommation de
marijuana au canada par j'ajoute des
détails dans le politicien bien en vue
aujourd'hui au pays
oui ça vous dit quelque chose justin
trudeau
justin trudeau mais à quelle occasion je
me raconte dominguez dont il était déjà
député
oui à montréal à la chambre des communes
oui et dans quelle oui il avait accordé
une entrevue au huffington post
c'est à dire film est-il et des biens et
puis et puis après ça il a été
pourchassé par des journalistes alors
qu'il sortait je pense de l'assemblée
nationale au québec ou de la ville de
mauriac en tout ça se passe au québec et
on lui a demandé avez-vous vraiment
fumée est ce que vous êtes sérieux et là
elle a annoncé bien sur ses intentions
de des crimes unit les une affaire il
était alors député que moody et nuit
maintenant il est premier ministre
voici l'extrait voici notre vidéo virale
reconstitué par l'équipe de tam-tam
canada mais oui j'ai déjà essayé je n'ai
jamais tenus
j ai j'ai essayé peut-être cinq ou six
fois dans depuis vous êtes élus et leurs
noms dans la vie au complet je lui
racontais j'étais dans un souper entre
amis chez moi sur la terrasse en arrière
de la maison il ya quelqu'un qui avait
un joint il l'a allumé on l'a passé j'ai
ptet j'ai pris une baffe et j'ai et je
les passais à la prochaine personne
c'est pour quelque chose qui est du du
de l'inconnu pour la grande majorité des
canadiens est ce que pour vous ce tuner
non c'est pas une erreur je ne consomme
pas du cannabis je suis pas un grand
consommateur du tout j'ai déjà essayé et
je trouve que c'est un exemple où la
population et les citoyens sont
complètement ailleurs que la masse
politique surtout que ce gouvernement si
qui continuent d'attaquer et des tags
récifs là dessus une des raisons pour
laquelle je suis accro l'égalisation
c'est que justement ça va nous permettre
d'éliminer beaucoup plus l'accès aux
jeunes à la marijuana
même ceux qui sont en désaccord avec moi
mon respecter le fait que je me base sur
la science je respecte le choix la
liberté de choix des autres et je suis
ouvert et intègre dans la façon de jouer
voici jeu-questionnaire premier jeu
questionnaire aujourd'hui sur 36
millions de canadiens combien consomme
de la marijuana sur 36 millions de
canadiens consomment de la marina
on va demander à leonardo d'y aller de
sa du chiffre qui n'est plus un demi
cent mille jeu 36 millions pas beaucoup
c'est une loi importante pour si peu de
gens c'est celle qui veut le faire ok
bien leonardo à 10 100 1000 vouloir en
bon blague 5 millions de canal
m annuellement chaque année la moins une
fois à une reprise à ce cas de la
marijuana et on estime que cette
nouvelle loi qui rend à la sphère légale
va augmenter le nombre de consommateurs
de combien de milliers dont les nuits
humiliantes de milliers au cours des
premières années on n'a pas les lignes
on verra ça après cinq mille neuf cent
mille vous à 150 mille sept cent
cinquante mille dollars ou leonardo
millions de plus 2 millions il n'a pas
la bonne réponse c'est 150 milles on
pense qu'ils s'installent de plus aux
coups
la première année mais si on se fie à
l'expérience du colorado
on vient d'entendre cette semaine à
radio canada qui est dans le colorado il
ya eu même une diminution des gens qui
consomment la marijuana après que la loi
a passé nous on fait des surdoses ou
quoi non non non non mais c'est parce
qu'ils ont eu la permission fossé sa
part augmenté sa pop mon nom était
réseau alors écoutez j'ai quelque chose
à vous faire entendre et surtout à ceux
qui sont sur facebook live en ce moment
et qui veulent savoir à quoi ça rime
cette nouvelle loi
comment ça va affecter les jeunes
surtout parce que c'est ça la grande
question oui c'est ça très bien alors
voici pour situer l'action
un reportage une partie de reportages
préparés par radio canada international
cette semaine et avec quelques
intervenants est établi à 18 ans est
clair que les gens ici à l'alcool et aux
drogues avant l'âge de 18 ans c'est sûr
que va falloir qu'on travaille de façon
différente par conséquent la même chose
travailler par de la prévention les
destins sont illégales berceuses et 5
sont légales quand on fait de la
prévention de la guerre et toutes les
écoles sont deux substances légales bien
qu'elle soit à 80 pour le jeune c'est
acceptable puisque c'est légal donc là
on va entrer dans cette famille là
également le cannabis déjà pour les
jeunes ce qu on entend déjà sur le
terrain des jeunes si c'est possible
parce que on va le légaliser
et comme donc de jeu qu'il fasse cette
association là il y aura un risque en
fait légale
gaby et égalise pour pas de danger pas
de problème et pas de risque à consommer
donc dans nos actions préventives va
falloir évidemment temps d'aller dans
les perceptions des jeunes puis voir
comment ils ont été repris évidemment le
fait que ça soit légal donc je pense que
ça va changer des pratiques des jeunes
ou du moins ce que ça va changer leur
façon de motiver leur consommation de
tabac c'est légal donc c'était les gars
c'est que c'est pas grave
malgré le fait qu' il y ait des risques
pour le développement des jeunes route
faut pas perdre de vue que la
prohibition n'a d'abord pas du tout
empêché les jeunes de confort est dans
le top 5 mondial bon hamala c'est très
accessible et jeunes canal réduit le
site la crise
quelqu'un a dit jean sébastien fallu et
professeur à l'école de psychoéducation
de l'université de montréal et fondateur
du groupe de recherche et d'intervention
psychosociale grip mais où il a pris un
elle-même pas pour rien que les kofi
annan et louise arbour de feu demandera
comment d'aller gagner à forte parce que
c'est bon pour la frapper ou qui a pas
de rire parce que la prohibition en
elle-même a des conséquences d'une
ampleur incommensurables sur à peu près
toutes les femmes mais la société en
faire et donc dans ce sens le oui il ya
peut-être des risques mais je trouve
assez irresponsable et médecins qui
disent donnons accès à 25 bon 21 c'est
un peu plus raisonnable mais il faut
savoir que les lic consommateurs le plus
grand nombre de consommateurs se
retrouvent se dédisent 25,1 et c'est
complètement incohérent avec l'accès à
l'alcool qui est pourtant un produit
pour lequel on devrait beaucoup plus
préoccupés parce que les dommages sont
beaucoup mieux documenter beaucoup plus
importants notamment sur le cerveau de
veau de lait alors il ya beaucoup
d'incohérences alors maintenant les
réactions du public
que ceux qui nous écoutent en ce moment
ce que des réactions à leonardo il ya
des gens qui disent bon jour qui
s'allument mais pas de réaction sur la
marijuana l'inquiétait gens très
détendue la réaction quand même sur le
web quand on a posé une autre question
par rapport à pour ou contre ce projet
de loi
d'abord mathieu je plainds quitte au
québec on n'a pas de données permettant
de confirmer la faire anne-marie
qu'est-ce qu'il dit exactement
alors il dit pour éviter de plus
d'aspects illégal je crois qu'il serait
préférable d'en vendre à toute personne
majeure 18 ans au québec
21 ans ailleurs aux catnat ils sont
moins responsables aucun surplus est 19
heures parce que ses 19 ans dans bien
des provinces pour pouvoir consommer de
l'alcool
c'est à partir des 18 ans et à colorado
21 ans il dit restreindre la marijuana
aux plus de 25 ans ne respecterait pas
la charte des droits et libertés des
canadiens puisque les plus grands
consommateurs sont âgés entre 20 et 24
ans et il en fut meuron autant je vous
le garantis chez micheline sauvé au
québec
leonora qu'est ce que la sas et oui
c'est un commentaire assez dur micheline
dit je suis content là l'église la
légalisation de la marijuana en ayant
perdu un enfant qui avait un problème en
santé mentale et une dépendance avec la
consommation des drogues
c'est là a détruit sa vie ma fille s'est
enlevé la vie
légaliser cette drogue c'est de
banaliser les conséquences de ce que
cette drogue peut faire vis-à-vis les
plus vulnérables alors le contre
maintenant le port avec tristan lortie
anne-marie von ah oui alors vous trouvez
ici il dit la marijuana n'est pas plus
dangereuse que le tabac en réalité ce
serait le tabac que l'on devrait bannir
puisque c'est cette substance en
particulier qui est la plus mortelle de
tout à travers le monde
de plus les arrestations pour la
possession de cannabis sont vraiment des
pertes de temps et de ressources
encore un nouveau moyen de remplir les
coffres du gouvernement est de faire
beau
j'ai notre économie réveillez-vous et
légalisons la marijuana récréative
calvin qui dit la chose suivante
et puis il ne ménage pas ses mots
leonardo venir n'aura quelle variante
moi qui ai pris quelques photos à vous
c'est menacer la sas évoqué il dit si
vous êtes assez stupide pour légaliser
la marijuana vous n'êtes vraiment pas
brillant si la marijuana est légal ça
n'existerait plus votre g dépôt à 10 $
potes de marijuana parce que c'est le
gouvernement parce que c'est le
gouvernement qui touche l'augmentation
j'imagine l'argent tchèque bat seul et g
avant 5 $ ca pour avorter parce que le
gouvernement sommet se met de la partie
mais il commençait sa lettre il faut on
sait qu'on peut gagner des imbéciles
gagner alors c'est ce qu'il dit est ce
qu'ils ont lancé cette initiative le
gramme à 10 $ moi je suis vraiment pas
un spécialiste fait des années que je ne
le suis plus spécialiste de ce genre de
choses alors dit d'argent c'est à dire
c'est mieux je pense créer le
gouvernement prend cet argent là qu'est
le crime organisé et à ce moment là
le gouvernement va investir cette argent
l'avant des programmes sociaux dans la
prévention se serait passé c'est la
jauge et c'est ce qui s'est fait un nom
du web et au colorado
moi j'ai lu un peu seul pour comparer
les deux ça m'intéresse beaucoup
alors c'est mieux que le gouvernement
aille les contrôles de cet argent
mais le crime organisé est déjà bien
intéressé par mail à l'égalisation j'ai
dix ans pour cultiver pour justement on
est quelque chose qui s'en vient pour
illustrer vos propos un pour documenter
avec des spécialistes ce que veut dire
mais avant tout le jeu questionnaire
numéros deux des missions aujourd'hui
alors voici la vaste gamme piège demande
de cannabis devrait rapporter qu'on
guide de dollars en chiffre d'affaires
lors de la première année au canada au
gouvernement canadien et aux premiers
secours ont la responsabilité bien sûr
j'ai la défense pour une voix et des
colorado je suis pas sûr pour le canada
alors à nous le guen c'était à peu près
35 millions la première année au
colorado c'était 4 millions mais là
cette année ils pensent que ce soit yvon
avoir 5 millions 2,5 millions de vies de
biographies bon au canada ce serait
combien 40 millions 40 millions cinq ans
50 millions tu peux plus donc oui dans
ma tête j'avais pensé 42 millions 42
minutes
il faut multiplier par dix noms oui ou
par keynes les estimés sont les suivants
ça a été fait par le responsable des
budgets à ottawa il ya un bureau spécial
pour ça c'est une analyse indépendante
n'a rien à voir avec le monde politique
et le second rôle a estimé qu' on
rapporterait 418 à 618 millions $ de la
première année c'est beaucoup plus cher
c'est ça c'est parce que beaucoup de
consommateurs et si les noms irigoin
c'est quoi la population est restée loin
millions et des mim a même pas 4
millions mais il ya deux cent mille
consommateurs
mais ici à 5 millions un ebit a nominé
jeu questionnaire oui mais ça combien de
millions ici trouver là-bas c'est trois
points sont alors voici maintenant
explication scientifique
combien ça va rapporter au gouvernement
pluriel au canada nous avons peu paris
c'est ce courage avis de spécialistes et
pas seulement il ne faut pas qu'une taxe
trop ils ne peuvent pas trouver beaucoup
de passes fiscale lentement au début de
marché de marijuana de cannabis dégâts
la france habilités des prix les gens
sont très très sensible à la variation
du prix d'un produit comme la mairie
ouanna on a des exemples ailleurs on
dans notre modèle on a démontré qu'on a
pris un dollar de plus pour le marché
légal congrès du marché illégal des
jaunes la déconsommation par abc sadique
on passait de d'une part de consommation
2 56% à 35 % du marché légal juste parce
que le marché légal couteau de chasse
alors le guen vous verserez très
physique
ils peuvent pas jouer beaucoup de sur ce
marché de taille aussi longtemps que le
marché illégal
il dégage du billet ne sera pas plus
démanteler cette erreur qu'il sera
passée dans lequel je marchais les gars
comme à la rive damas
c'est pas quelque chose pour être facile
pour le monde 2 ans drilles de pénétrer
ce marché de façon légale parce que le
marché illégal sera toujours ou en
répandant interprétant les fiv en cuir
incomplète mais le projet de loi prévoit
que les provinces auront le droit de
décider comment la marijuana sera
distribué et vendu ou si surtout à quel
prix douce n'apparaît donc faire
chavirer un modèle de commercialisation
et donc les revenus
s'il ya trop d'écart entre les provinces
donc il faut que l'âge soit à peu près
le même accès au cannabis soit peu près
la même que les points de distribution
soit similaire
et c'est serge brochu et directeur
scientifique de l'institut universitaire
sur les dépenses à l'université de
montréal premier ministre justin trudeau
nous mentionne que c'est pour mieux
contrôler et pour enlever les énormes
profits qu fait le marché criminel
bon ben si on veut éliminer ce profit au
niveau d'une hanche est lumineuse se
soit pas du jour au lendemain
vos premièrement essaie de garder une
partie du marché donc si les taux de thc
sont limités dont à 5% au niveau de la
vente légale elles vont essayer de se
spécialiser dans une niveau de th il un
peu plus élevé si les heures d'ouverture
sont ne sont pas compatibles avec les
arts de consommation ils vont se
spécialiser dans ce créneau
mais si on leur laisse pas suffisamment
d'espacé au niveau du marché illégal et
c'est souhaitable
ils vont essayer de rester sur le marché
donc de façon légale parce qu'ils
connaissent très bien les normes profits
qu'ils peuvent faire restant sur ce
marché et encore
réaction cette semaine sur nos
différents services à rci ont recueilli
les opinions des gens par rapport à
céder l'égalisation et c'est par rapport
aux commerces qu'on va en faire l'argent
qu'on pourrait en tirer d'abord anne
marie williams il écrit la chose
suivante alors il dit aucune dépendance
n'est liée à la consommation de
marijuana
vous vous fourvoyez dans les fausses
campagnes de sensibilisation en
légalisant le cannabis mieux sera
l'économie est dorénavant il ne sera
plus aussi mal conçu je parle ici de
tout ce que le marché noir peut shooter
sur celui ci
ce sera donc une consommation beaucoup
plus saine martin scott brazeau merlin
leonora matin il dit il est temps
d'avoir du changement au canada si on
regarde à colorado depuis la
légalisation de la marijuana
ils ont payé deux tours deux tiers 2/3
merci de leurs dettes actuelles
ainsi moi même pas si - donc en les
rendant légal imaginez les changements
que ça va donner
dix mille diminution des gangs des rues
diminution des dettes
et puis même après quelques années
diminution des taxes qu'on paye un trop
bon maintenant je voudrais vous montrer
à quoi va ressembler le futur ici au
canada on a une petite machine à
remonter dans le temps ici à l'émission
elle est bien connu on utilise une fois
de temps en temps nous allons maintenant
nous rendent même pas une surprise j'ai
dû passer vous amener au colorado
ça produit là oui il ya le lourd go est
donc un oui et puis il ya le colorado on
va aller au colorado on a une équipe là
bas qui s'est déplacé sur youtube ont
été repêchés des images sur youtube ça
ne nous appartient pas mais ça vous
montre à quoi ressemble une clinique
comme un docteur mais clinique barry
ouanna et acheter vos produits vous
allez voir le celui qui vous 20 et
protégé derrière un écran pour vérifier
qu'ils vous êtes parce qu'on ne veut pas
laisser rentrer qu'il veut ou qui
pourraient et puis aussi on va regarder
ça pendant qu'on parle on va faire
travailler notre imagination celles à
venir au canada
on sait qu'on sait pas encore quoi ça va
être il ya quand même une hésitation en
col parce que les pharmaciens disent
qu'il faut se protéger aussi on sait
jamais il ya des délinquants qui vont
venir les statistiques vous savez en
france une formation d'un personnel
droguerie oui c'est ça voilà sa porte
bien son nom
alors c'est à ça que ça va ressembler ce
qu'on voit les images en ce moment les
orientaux oui à l'envoyer en est là où
vous arrivez au comptoir ya un gentil
garçon qui va vous proposer une
sélection dans quelques instants la
sélection complète de différents
produits
alors pour les anxieux ceux qui parce
qu'anna qui sont requis qui deviennent
le père paranoïaque quelqu'un s'il
consomme
il ya certaines variétés qu'on pourra
vous conseiller qui sont plus douces
pour votre pauvre n'a l'air vous savez
ce qui est intéressant c'est que là on
va savoir ce qu'on achète à savoir scabs
honneur à la mairie a dû cesser ça me
rassure pas aussi important c'est de nos
qualités oui y'a pas de chimie qu'aucun
chimical mélange là on sait ça va de
surprises en palestine de mauvaises
surprises un samedi anodin
ce matin un autre voilà voilà parce que
ce qu'on achète au coin de la rue denis
on ne sait pas d'où ça vient bon ben ça
sacré c'est une question de santé
publique ans et je sais que nora n'est
pas tout à fait en faveur de la
légalisation de la marijuana
les adolescents chez les adolescents
auxquels les cerveaux des adolescents
n'est pas encore formé et complètement
alors il ya des cas où et des jeunes et
des adolescents ont développé les
schizophrénies par exemple et c'est la
marijuana qui a déclenché cette maladie
n'a vraiment été capable de faire le
lien de cause à effet oui oui oui je
pense que oui alors c'est pour ça que
les médecins s'opposent à donner ça aux
adolescents en fait c'est un tout un
autre débat sain il faudra certainement
peut-être image et sa voir vérifier ça
avec dans le cas de nos entrevues
reportages c'est tout pour cette semaine
malheureusement dans ses toiles édition
avec un produit voilà n'auront rien même
pas de chocolat chocolat petit lapin
pourrait continuer ça dans ma tête si
vous perdez votre terme
ça sent bon alors c'est de la vraie
terre du magasin alors merci beaucoup à
marivan d'être venu cette semaine
toujours un plaisir
merci en arrivant du secteur de espace
autochtone de radio canada
leonardo comme frères et soeurs leonora
jardinier la section latino-américaine
merci de nous avoir fait plaisir à
briser des joyeuses pâques vraiment
joyeuse pâques à vous également les
mêmes si logique de la section espagnole
radio aussi l'international alors qu'est
ce qu'on dit
[Musique]